Come with me, children, to a magical island
full of deadly snakes! Wait, that's a terrible
idea. Do not follow me.
Anthony here for DNews. When I was a kid I
used to read comics and books and watch old
movies that were all about setting foot on
a weird, uncharted island where animals had
their own advanced society.
No, I'm not about to tell you there's an island
of Ape Scientists out there.
And I'm sorry for that.
But there are a lot of islands that do have
a magical, overrun by animals vibe- from the
scary to the adorable to the weird.
Like Japan's Cat Island, Tashiro-jima. It's
a small fishing island off the coast of Ishinomaki
City that's home to about 100 people- and
way, way, way more stray cats. There's no
official population count, but thanks to a
local belief that feeding strays is good luck,
the cat population keeps growing.
Cat Island loves their cat population so much
that there's a shrine to them in the center
of the Island and tons of cat shaped buildings.
There are no pet dogs and they're pretty much
banned from being on the island at all.
While the cat population is growing, the human
one's falling- 83% of the people on Tashiro-jima
are elderly, with 50% of them being over 65.
They were also hit very hard by the 2011 tsunami.
Which means eventually, the island's going
to be cats only.
Then there's Christmas Island, which is a
territory of Australia and the only home in
the world to the Christmas Red Crab. They're
interesting because they can't swim- they
live entirely on land underground, away from
the seashore. But their young can only live
in water- so every year during monsoon season,
they make a long migration out of the rainforest
to the ocean- ALL 120 MILLION OF THEM.
They go in a completely straight line, following
these ancient migratory paths- they go right
through towns and roads. THEY DO NOT CARE
ABOUT ANYTHING. About a million of them die
in traffic every year but they're just like
"Whatever, I just laid 100,000 eggs. Deal
with it."
And if you live on Christmas Island, that
is exactly what you do. You just sort of avoid
them and step through them the best you can.
So ridiculous.
And finally, beware the deadly Snake Island.
Ilha de Queimada Grande- a 110 acre island
of the coast of Sao Paolo, Brazil. It's the
only home in the world of the Golden Lancehead
Viper, which is a species of pit viper.
And it's a deadly, mean-tempered sucker.
The effects of its venom are swelling, local
pain, nausea, vomiting, blood blisters, bruising,
blood in your vomit and urine, intestinal
bleeding... etc etc. You get it.
It's so deadly that the Brazilian navy won't
let anyone land on the island. There are anywhere
from 2000 and 4000 Golden Lanceheads just
lying in wait- which actually makes them endangered.
Due to inbreeding, wildfires, and illegal
animal poaching and trading, these guys are
dying out.
Okay, choose your own adventure time. You
can vacation on one magical animal island.
Which do you choose? I go christmas island-
I'll take weird over cute or deadly any day
of the week.
Hey, by the way, we've been doing this for
about two months now and we just wanted to
say thanks- you guys have been awesome and
it means a ton to us how much you've been
coming back and talking about our videos.
We've had a couple people we've seen commenting
on every video like Cocoalrose, LynneSkysong
and DK0526. Thank you guys for coming by every
day. And also a big thanks to Alex Vizzini
and Don Alba on twitter for spreading the
word about the show. You guys all rule and
we're excited to be doing something you care
about as much as we do. And if you're new
to the channel, welcome, please subscribe,
and we'll see you soon.